hi guys we're going to talk about your
in color and what that means okay so
first of all I wanted to make it a
little disclaimer if you have any of
these conditions I'm not telling you had
those for sure they're just clues
I'm not diagnosing you so get with your
doctor if you have any issues with this
okay all right so the darker color urine
normally urine should be like a straw
yellow if it's too dark it's too
concentrated that means you do need to
drink more water okay if it's too clear
if it's completely clear there's no
color that means is too diluted you're
drinking too much water and when you're
doing that you're diluting the
electrolytes and that's weakening the
heart so it's not it's that it's there's
false information that states that oh
yeah everyone needs the clear urine
that's not true okay bright yellow that
usually happens after consuming too many
B vitamins your body is trying to get
rid of it especially since it's always
synthetic vitamins it just goes right
through you it's not absorb so it's a
good indication that you're taking
synthetic red dark red means you have
blood in the urine now you could have a
kidney stone or like me about I'd say
about six months ago one day I just
started peeing this red blood coming out
and it freaked me out I was like what's
happening here do I have a kidney stone
this is weird I'm eating good and
everything well it just happened to go
for this this intense jog and it was
completely human and I was sweating and
I pushed myself and I'm running hard
longer than I normally do and apparently
I found out because I went to get it
checked there's no bacterial infection
there's no kidney that pounding up and
down especially in certain high levels
of heat even if you're doing marathons
you'll see that the kidneys will just
like pound and see the urine is this
filtered blood through the kidneys so
you're just taking the kid in your whip
lashing that thing all this Bloods gonna
come right through unfiltered and that's
what it was because the next day I
completely went away but got me freaked
out there for a second so then we have
darker orange or brown that's
litora issue so you need to start going
up with your vegetables at that point
and cut out the junk get the junk out of
the trunk right pink could be your
eating beets or it could be a little
blood yet a little kidney stone in which
case take potassium citrate and then
green could be asparagus now if the
urine is foamy that's usually more
protein in the urine that should be
there so your kidney is supposed to
filter out that protein so it's either
you're consuming too much protein or the
kidneys need some support so if that's
the case you might want to you know
watch some videos and the kidney above
what what to do about that and then
check with your dock as well but protein
usually is not a good thing and it can
be serious so you want to get that
checked out but that's more of like a
foaming situation but first make sure
that it's you know not something simple
like you just ate a lot of protein and
then all of a sudden your body could
have that protein so it's spilled off
into the urine all right thanks for
watching I'll see you next video hey
guys thank you so much for watching
please click the subscribe button and I
will see you in the next video